this morning I saw your video where you
guys are posting that how late did you
guys stay up cuz you were at the Critics
Choice Awards last night how they didn't
stay up late we woke we went to bed and
woke up at like yeah they woke up at
like 4:00 I woke up at like 5:00 o - I
woke up yeah alright so it was set up
like we're going to be in Noah's room at
5 a.m. because they were announcing and
so I woke up at 4:58
and I put on some shorts and I walked
down to his hotel room and bare feet and
we just surfed through the channels
found the channel and we just waited and
they videoed it waited it out what was
the experience like for you guys on your
first big carpet last night at the
Critics Choice the first of many that
are to come
I mean they were on the Emmys carpet
that was their biggest but that was my
biggest thing I've ever been on that was
Ingraham I mean it was from the Blucher
booboo gardener but it was the way it
was the weirdest experience my wife and
we wanted yeah because like I saw like
all my acting hairs in one night which
is weird and like uh like I'll be
talking to one part like I was talking
like I was talking all the modern family
people like Julie Bowen how much of huge
fans there and like Donald Glover will
just walk past me and like hey Hugh
Shannon like what like in one night like
all in one room yeah and you can meet so
many cool people in one night um you
know and and yeah yeah you guys are
wearing a tux we were yes I mean I'm
gonna I was where I was wearing a tux -
it was nice and I liked it it was
definitely fun yeah and now you got the
Golden Globes that you gotta wear a tux
for again right and it's another big
carpet event last night you told one of
us that you liked you wanted to meet
Viola Davis do you think that's gonna
happen
yeah we met her actually yes yeah what
we may we met her yeah uh-huh yeah Tom
it's crazy that it's just you look
around and there's that person in that
pose it's just because some people don't
even have the courage to approach people
like they're your biggest fans and they
go up to us they're celebrities and they
want to meet them you just went up to
him would you say well we just tap their
shoulder and said hi and then we started
talking and she knew who you guys were
obviously well she did it she was we
were like hey she's like oh hey but she
was really nice though she's like hey
there's like stranger things she's like
okay cool
they are you guys enjoying it it's like
yeah we're enjoying she's all nice
meeting you guys so in she it's like we
were just walking down the thing embrace
shouts Howard's over there would say hey
Lee its Bryce Dallas Howard right behind
the washing jeffrey tambor like what no
work oh yeah it's just like people just
will walk around you be like wait what
if they hide everybody I don't have time
all right so
Wynonna is also nominated you guys
picked her at all today no we didn't we
yeah not yet are you going to call or
find a way to call her yeah we're gonna
try we're gonna try to find out yeah so
we can congratulate my texts to her but
I we we should all we should all like
talk to her when when we get there how
people see her this week because we get
back cheering okay
so what's it like working with Wynonna
and being on set together oh it's
amazing experience because she's iconic
and just a just a watcher and getting so
many so much information because she was
a young actress in the 80s and we can
learn a lot of stuff from her so that's
definitely a room that's a big role
model for us so yeah that's great yeah
just like being on set with her she's
just so sweet and I'm always learning
new stuff with her like she taught me
like if the sound is off and you're just
supposed to be pretend to talking
pretend to be talking she said to say
carrots and peas rhubarb over and over
and over and and I learned that from her
so I want to know something from you I
was watching last season and then it
ended with something coming out of your
mouth can we talk a little bit about it
can you give us a spoiler for Canada
well you saw that obviously its I threw
up a slug and and it's it's obviously
going to affect me physically and
mentally but I can't say anything yet
but it's exciting what happens next
season